in politics now i'm finding that it is
just fear
let's create enough fear and then we can
then have this really intrusive policy
and it doesn't matter
what the outcome is whether or not that
policy will have the outcome of
improving the environment that just goes
out the window and that's what's really
frustrating to me as someone who has an
education in environmental studies that
we are not seeing that the policies have
a
a positive outcome on the environment
the idea that we have to accept
arbitrary limits to growth economic
growth which are mostly going to hurt
poor people and higher energy prices and
higher food prices which are mostly
going to hurt poor people and that
that's going to help on the
environmental sustainability front
that's just
it's not only nonsense and a lie
it's an anti-truth you couldn't say
anything farther from the truth than
that
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased today to be
talking to dr leslie lewis
dr lewis is a candidate for the
leadership of the conservative party in
canada at the federal level
and although this is a podcast with an
international audience
the leadership race in canada on the
conservative front turns out to be
something of some surprising
international significance
not least i think because our prime
minister justin trudeau
who i'm not a fan of for those of you
who don't know
is a real poster boy for the
globalist utopians who are busily
attempting to make this planet far worse
and so the best challenge to trudeau
on the political front in canada will
definitely come from the conservative
party who have been the historical
alternatives to canada's liberals
and
dr lewis is a
sig
a signally important
participant in that conservative
leadership
process
she's more i think it's fair to say on
the socially conservative front but a
very interesting person and so
she's
agreed to talk to me today which i also
think is a good thing i've talked to
pierre pauliev who's the front-runner in
the race and roman bobber
so that'll be three including dr lewis
that'll be three of the five candidates
i reached out to jean charae who used to
be premier of quebec but his team
felt that speaking to a ripper bait such
as myself was probably not in his
interest and there's another candidate
hsn who i haven't yet talked with and
perhaps still might if time
makes that possible but we'll start with
the bio
leslie lewis graduated with a bachelor's
degree from the university of toronto
trinity college graduating magna
laude she has a master's degree in
environmental studies from york
university with a concentration in
business and environment from the
schulich school of business and a juris
doctor from osgood hall law school and a
phd in law from osgood hall law school
she and her family are residents of the
town of dunville
where she serves her community as member
of parliament for holdem and norfolk
leslie
exploded onto the national political
scene
when she ran previously for the
leadership of the conservative party in
despite having no pre-established
political network and coming from
relative obscurity her vision of a
strong united and prosperous nation
resonated with canadians right across
the country she finished in third place
in the race
winning the popular vote ahead of
eventual winner aaron o'toole and party
co-founder peter mckay
dr lewis is currently running for the
second time in the current battle for
the canadian
conservative federal leadership so
welcome
dr lewis thank you very much for making
time it's quite exciting to have the
opportunity to engage in these long-form
discussions on the political front i
think that's something perhaps
revolutionary in canadian politics to be
able to circumvent the legacy media
let's say so uh welcome to the podcast
thank you it's a great pleasure to be
here and i'm very honored to be here
with you today
yeah so people uh we might as well start
right from the beginning let's do a
little bit of a
biographical uh uh discussion to begin
with
um
tell me a bit about your family
tell me about your background and and
then also
you're very well educated and then you
made a foray into politics let's walk
through that a little bit so that we can
place you in everyone's imagination
before we move to the policy side of
things
well as you said i reside in a small
community called dunville it's in the
riding of haldeman norfolk which is in
the niagara area
south of hamilton
for those of you who are familiar with
southern ontario and as you said i've
recently just uh emerged into politics
and i felt a calling on my life to
really serve use my skills that i have
honed over the last few decades in
education in law and
just practical business experience use
that to better my country because right
now i see that our country is at a
precipice and i'm concerned about the
future of our country i'm concerned
about my children and the future that
they will have and the dreams that i've
had in this country and that i've been
able to realize i'm very concerned that
they won't be there for future
generations when we look at the 1.3
trillion dollars that we have in debt
and the fact that every day just to
service that debt we're paying over 140
million dollars a day just in interest
payments just to service that debt and
the fact that my children
will owe 45 000 is their share of the
national debt and so there are so many
things that are happening in this world
that are having influences on whether or
not we will survive as a sovereign
nation and so i think that my experience
lending my experience to this cause is
one of the most noble things that i feel
that i've done in my life
so when you were when you were
in university you you you spent a lot of
time in university let's walk through
your education
well maybe maybe uh that didn't used to
be a problem although it's become one
um let's walk through your university
career and then tell me about your
developing interest in politics so
um
what your first degree was at the
university of toronto
yes it's actually in sociology african
studies with a minor in women's studies
and philosophy
so as you can see i have well versed in
the social sciences and i understand the
language of many things that are
transpiring now
i
went through the education system and
throughout my education i often felt
that i was in an environment that
they were trying to mold me but
in the earlier years at the university
of toronto i had the ability to at least
i knew where where the limits were but i
also had the ability to to challenge
whereas i found in my later stages that
things there was more conformity in
education and there was less um
diversity of thought which was very very
concerning to me and even in my later
days of teaching i almost felt like an
undercover agent
um
because i i couldn't really necessarily
reveal that i was conservative
although it came out later on because i
was asked to help out the party in 2015
at the end of my phd
and uh to to run in an election in a
riding that there was a scandal in and
so i had to step in last minute so at
the end it was revealed but i don't
think that many people uh were really
cognizant of of how much of a
conservative i was because that's not
something that's really really
celebrated in university and that sounds
like really ironic that one would say
that that in a institution of higher
learning that you would not be able to
celebrate diversity of thought but
that's what the end of my university
career was like and that's really
unfortunate
what years were you studying sociology
and women's studies at the university of
toronto
oh in the 90s in the
early 90s i completed my first degree
okay so that that's a very both
sociology and women's studies are very
left-leaning certainly now but they were
back in the nine early 1990s too there
was kind of a little initial peak of
political correctness in the
universities in the early 1990s so two
questions there
why did you decide to go into sociology
and women's studies and
were you conservative in your
orientation then
and
and um
if so how did you bridge that gap
well actually my family came here as
immigrants and the liberal party was the
party that they felt most at home in and
so although i grew up in an ultra ultra
conservative family
uh
religious wise um
economically fiscally conservatives
just a traditional immigrant family that
comes
to canada and has the foundations of
strong family values uh believing in in
strong faith values and that strong
faith in your in your community and
contributing to that community so i
would consider myself as growing up in a
conservative family although it was a
politically liberal family and when i
went to school i didn't even think about
politics at all i just wanted to get an
education and i was concerned about some
of the social dilemmas because i was
very active uh in my church doing prison
ministry
working with at-risk youth and so i was
very concerned about the social dilemmas
and so sociology was a natural fit and
sociology really was about understanding
the
theoretical underpinnings
of of what really
compris of what society was comprised of
so it was a lot of theory and so i
didn't really find that it was
left-leaning woman studies of course
that was that was my minor and that was
more so left-leaning but it was still
very theoretical back then now what i'm
finding is a lot of the theories have
become dogma and have have seeped into
the mainstream narrative and have become
the norm rather than just a theory and
so that's the difference between what i
went to school in the 90s and what
studied now
and you could have
alternative positions back then whereas
now i find that you're demonized for
having critical uh thought abilities
okay so the advantage of that would have
been to have gone through that four-year
initial period would have been that you
became conversant very conversant say
with the progressive views
the
downside would have been well the
tension that you would have experienced
i presume between your beliefs and the
beliefs that were being promoted
why
why weren't you convinced by the more
progressive doctrines of the
sociologists and the women studies
teachers and what did that do to your
what did experiencing that tension for
four years
do to the way that you conceptualized
your philosophy and your practical
approach
well it it does it does shape you even
even though you have that conservative
foundation that education does impact on
you because there are things that i had
bought into
that i'm just even now recognizing that
may not have been
all-encompassing or may not have been
ideally where i would have been had i
not had that education so there was a
notion that i i had to just
my success was really based on what
i could materially
get from society or
my
educational pursuits and
and it was there was a lot of friction
there with also raising a family and
having a successful marriage etc so many
of that i think
may have even undermined some of the
traditional values that i had
and i don't know whether that's a good
or a bad thing because i was able to
reconcile it and even in university i
joined the reform party because i
saw that preston manning his values were
very much in line with what i believed
and there were questions that i
had through my education that weren't
being adequately answered and so i just
naturally gravitated towards my
upbringing and i found that he as a
leader was somebody who
i i believed was a very dignified and
upstanding
person and i
i saw the values that he
had for and the desires that he had for
this country and so i aligned myself
with that party very early on so do you
think
for having been educated on the
progressive front
do you think that you developed
a deeper appreciation for the
perspective that's being put forward
there i mean the progressive
argument is something like
people who have authority and status
often benefit from unfair privilege and
opportunity
and capitalize on power
let's say at the expense of people who
are
less fortunately situated in the
hierarchical structure of society
you know there's some truth to that
obviously because power corrupts
every human institution and we have to
keep an eye out on it
why do you think you were unconvinced
by the more radical stream of the
progressive doctrine especially given
that you were immersed in it for
for four years and subject to a fair bit
i imagine both of conceptual and peer
pressure
well as i said it from a theoretical
perspective a lot of it does make sense
the problem that i'm having
now is that it's almost being inversed
so we know that
privilege is relative i often times i've
i've
walked into a room and people would say
say to me oh you're a lawyer how they
would know that um perhaps by the way i
speak by the way i carry myself so there
is relative privilege in different
aspects of your social ranking and
that's that's something that we've
always had in society the reason why i
speak about an inversion is because
what i'm seeing is that
they
they will often
make your identity your master status
and so that's what i push back on right
now because we were able to critically
analyze why that is not good for society
but i even find myself right now even in
the conservative race as someone who has
only the only track record of someone
running a conservative leadership race
and winning the popular vote as an
outsider i still will not get
media coverage and attention primarily
because i don't fit their narrative and
their narrative is that the conservative
party is a white racist party and so to
have me um potentially highlight me
would go against the media and the
social narrative so much to the point
that in 2020 kamala harris was featured
over 80 800 times more than i was even
though she was not running um in our
country and even though her her position
was an appointment and i was running to
earn my position as a
leadership candidate as the leader of
the conservative party so
those things
it shows you largely how um the left
kind of
they've reversed even what their beliefs
are to the point that when you don't fit
their narrative they come after you and
they attack you very very viciously
we'll have more with dr leslie lewis in
just a moment first i want to tell you
about birch gold the consumer price
index has reached yet another 40-year
high and the latest gdp numbers
confirmed that the united states is in a
recession now is not the time to have
all your money in a stock market or tied
to the us dollar protect your savings
from a highly turbulent economy by
diversifying at least some of your
investment portfolio into gold and
silver from birch gold group text jordan
to 989898 and birch gold will send you a
free information kit on how to
transition an ira or eligible 401k into
an ira in precious metals birch gold
will even help you hold gold in a tax
sheltered account for decades investors
have relied on gold and silver as a
hedge against inflation now you can too
with an a plus rating from the better
business bureau countless five-star
reviews and thousands of satisfied
customers secure your future with gold
from birch gold now text jordan to
989898 and get real help from birch gold
today again text jordan to 989898 to
claim your free no obligation
information kit on how to protect your
hard-earned savings with gold
so it's very perverse say because you're
you're
objecting on philosophical grounds to
the idea that you should be categorized
by
let's say your race and your sex
and yet the left insists that that's the
cardinal distinction between people and
then insist that people like that should
be brought to the forefront because
they've been marginalized and then
insists that that should only be the
case clarence thomas is a good case in
point two who's been pilloried like mad
for not fitting the mold so despite the
fact that you have the uh let's say
self-evident characteristics that the
left is trumpeting the fact that you
aren't
conducting yourself in a manner that
seems to be ideologically appropriate
means that in some real sense
that you're persona non grata and that
really is interest that's the inversion
that you're speaking about that really
is a fascinating phenomenon as far as
i'm concerned
so
um all right so after you were at the
university of toronto
your next degree was what
a masters of environmental studies okay
so that's a bit of a that's a bit of a
detour now now you're in you've jumped
from one leftist hotbed
into
an even more leftist hotbed i would say
because not only are you taking
environmental studies you're taking
environmental studies at york which is
definitely one of canada's i mean that
place is paralyzed by strikes about
every two years it's i would say it's
fair to say that must be one of canada's
most
leftist higher educational institutions
and so now you've jumped into
environmental studies why environmental
studies and why york and what was that
like
to be honest with you i don't even know
why i decided to
choose environmental studies other than
the fact that i had a deep
concern about the environment about our
stewardship
and it was
it wasn't some thing that i thought that
i was going to make a lot of money from
or that it was
on a desired path it was almost like
a honing signal like something that sent
out to you and drawing you
to that but you can't really put your
finger on why it is that you
did that degree
and that's the just the best way i can
explain it i'm very happy that i did do
that and even that program was very very
different than what this environmental
studies is now even then i feel that i
had a well-rounded all-encompassing
education in the environment it wasn't
the the notion of climate change and the
politicization of climate change wasn't
something that i dealt with
as a a master's student in the
environment that that is a recent
phenomena that we've taken climate
change we've politicized it we've made
it a scientific and we've used it to as
a revenue generating tool to conjure up
fear
and that wasn't something that um that i
found in my in my studies so what did
you okay so let's go into that a little
bit so um what did you learn
in your couple of couple of years two
years master's program was it
what did you learn about the environment
and and and tell me how that shaped your
thinking now uh i'm a big fan people
know this i'm a big fan of bjorn lomberg
he's done a pretty comprehensive
analysis of sustainability and
environmental issues and also a man
named marion toopey who's wrote a great
book recently called super abundance
there both of them are trying very hard
to sort out
the priorities of the various
environmental concerns that do in fact
beset us what did you learn at york and
and
what do you think is of stellar
importance on the environmental front
confronting us now
well you'd be surprised what i learned
um well it's starting from the
theoretical perspective of
say sustainability our common future
that that notorious book
we started from that foundation but we
also learned we also learned the role of
big pharma and that that could be all
consuming we also learned about some of
the improprieties that were committed by
big pharma in uh southern in in in
southern nations whether it's south
america or african countries we also
learned about sustainability
and the role of farmers and generational
ability to sustain the land
intergenerational ability we learned
about the atmosphere and
in a very very different way than how
we're talking about it right now we
we knew that nitrogen made up 90 78 of
the atmosphere that oxygen made up 21
and that carbon was 0.04
so we talked about uh carbon reduction
in a very very different way than we
have done now which is more of a
politicized way
and it's it's completely different i'm
not sure what what is being taught now
in an environmental studies program but
it was fascinating because we looked at
things like the role of monsanto
and the appropriation of biodiversity
and how that will lead to
fewer choices for people in the farming
sector so it was something that i was
pre
preempted towards that i was pre-warned
um that these things were coming and
we've looked at even african communities
in the role of some of the united
nations food programs how they have
these actually destabilize those
communities if you look at um say um
reduce
there's a program called red reduce
emissions for deforestation and
degradation and that program basically
encouraged um
people in
certain african communities not to cut
down trees because they said it was
contributing to
um
a very bad carbon footprint it was
contributing to um
depletion and and and
carbonization of the environment etc and
so
they
encouraged those individuals not to cut
down trees and the people were hungry
they began to starve
you saw malnutrition in communities that
never had malnutrition before
and so they had to go back and say well
we are encouraging them not to cut down
these trees but they're starving other
in other projects they encouraged people
not to um
they were using corn for ethanol
and the people were going hungry and so
we we're looking at all of these
programs and you have to ask whether or
not it's serving humanity
and even if we look at our our situation
in canada and we look at even our
resource sector
in my master's program we were taught
that
uh resource development is not mutually
exclusive from environmental
sustainability that's what we were
taught and so we were we looked for ways
to solve problems whether that's through
efficient technology innovative
technology working with corporations um
to to to make sure that their impact or
their footprint can uh is minimal and
and that they can remedy um some of the
damage that's caused to the environment
so we looked for solutions whereas in
politics now i'm finding that it is just
fear
let's create enough fear and then we can
then have this really intrusive policy
and it doesn't matter what the outcome
is whether or not that policy will have
the outcome of improving the environment
that just goes out the window and that's
what's really frustrating to me as
someone who has an education
in environmental studies that we are not
seeing that the
policies have a
a positive outcome on the environment
it's just largely
revenue generating yeah you well you
brought up a bunch of issues there i
mean one issue i would say is
the idea that
somehow we have to make life difficult
for impoverished people
so that the environment will improve you
talked about the injunction to
cease deforestation and the consequent
generation of hunger the first thing
that i think
conservatives and intelligent liberals
could
agree upon and
insist upon is that
there's no pathway to environmental
sustainability
that involves making already poor people
more miserable
first of all because we shouldn't be
making them more miserable
that's for sure and second because
people can't care about broader
environmental concerns
when they're so desperate they're
worried about tonight's shelter and the
next meal
and so the idea that we have to accept
arbitrary limits to growth economic
growth which are mostly going to hurt
poor people and higher energy prices and
higher food prices which are mostly
going to hurt poor people and that
that's going to help on the
environmental sustainability front
that's just
it's not only nonsense and a lie it's an
anti-truth you couldn't say anything
farther from the truth than that
i completely agree with you dr peterson
in that
it's actually and i'll tell you a story
that happened to me uh during my math
actually it was during my phd
i was unable to publish a paper
because i referenced the term
environmental imperialism
and the peer-reviewed reviewers
told me i had to take that word out
in order to publish my paper so i said
absolutely not i won't do it so i had to
keep shopping it around to different
places i finally got it it published and
that's really what you're talking about
is environmental imperialism because
what the west is doing now is saying
we've developed and yes our path of
development wasn't good for the
environment
and we've learned and so now we want you
to learn and therefore we don't want you
to have all the luxuries that we have
because we've destroyed the environment
you stay in your state um of of no worse
exactly or worse
and and and we will find a way to
to protect the environment not
recognizing that you may want to
have electricity have some of the
luxuries that we have and instead of
finding a way
that we could um
for lack of a better word bring other
societies along to the path of
development in in an environmentally
sustainable way you have this notion of
environmental imperialism where you say
no you can't cut down that tree for food
because we want to protect the forest
it's it's an elitism that is coming into
environmental protection and
and it comes from and i'm going to use
the word privilege that it is a stance
of privilege i think that's a proper way
to use it that we in this society um we
have the privilege of having all these
luxuries and then we have the audacity
to tell people that they should not
strive for the same things in their
lives
not just to tell them to force them
under power of law to do so i mean we
look at what happened to sri lanka as a
case in point and you know my sense i
spent about two years studying issues of
environmental st st
sustainability and economic development
and that's when i realized which was a
great delight and shock to me that the
fastest way forward
to true environmental sustainability was
to eradicate poverty i thought well
that's a good deal we can eradicate
poverty and that'll be good for the
planet and then i also thought and tell
me what you think of this the pathway
forward
to
the amelioration of poverty and
environmental sustainability is let's
say to make the absolutely poor
richer because then they'll start to
care about the environment and so once
you get them up to about five thousand
dollars a year in gdp people start to be
concerned about longer term issues
because they can afford to and then
there's a pathway of development there
that's quite clear as far as i can tell
that involves cheap energy because
energy is work and energy is food and so
the pathway is something like well
people burn dung or wood it's better to
replace that with coal and then it's
better to replace the coal with oil and
the oil with natural gas and the natural
gas conceivably with nuclear and some
judicious mix of renewables and each of
those steps is somewhat more expensive
using current technology so generally
speaking countries have to pass through
that entire developmental sequence and i
know that the developing world is
planning to generate something like 170
coal-fired plants in the next few years
and then i don't know how many nuclear
plants china is planning to build but a
lot and so
instead of interfering with that and
making fossil fuel
unconscionably
expensive and then driving countries
like china to shop for
bad sources of coal instead of
relatively clean burning coal we're
moralizing like mad in our privilege in
the west and
we're dooming all these people to not
only privation and and want in a very
fundamental sense but to an
environmentally degraded future so the
bloody leftists on the environmental
front are not only getting
are not only putting forward a vision
that's contrary to a conservative vision
or a true liberal vision but they're
putting forward a vision that isn't
going to result in what they purport to
desire no absolutely and it goes even
beyond
say
electrifying the the south it it come it
goes into sustaining their
food source right and right now there is
a major attack on even their food source
if you take the situation in sri lanka
the situation in sri lanka is
not much different than than what we
will be facing here um ironically it
started off with lockdowns the lockdowns
really really crippled the average uh
person who made their living selling on
the streets through tourism vending
and
that impact
was still there when they imposed even
more restrictions
on the nitrogen content in the
fertilizer so you had people who were
used to making their money by selling
tea
tea farming and with the 30 30 nitrogen
content um reduction
their yields were much less and so they
couldn't
um
sustain themselves economically and then
you even had the rice farmers in sri
lanka also which is a large a staple
cash crop there and they also had to
deal with the nitrogen content reduction
and so they were making the type of
money so you don't have the the money
flowing through the system um that you
ordinarily would and then you have from
the lockdown um the supply chains were
so limited that the cost of everything
increased and the people have fewer
dollars to even purchase these items now
and so that's why you saw them raid the
presidential palace because
a light goes off why should these
politicians be living
in a palace in luxury while i cannot
even put one meal a day on the table for
my family and that's why they said
enough is enough okay so let's put that
let's put that in context now we talk
about the nitrogen issue so
um first thing
is that we've seen now a tremendous
amount of
un uh unhappiness
on the dutch farmer front so the
the
judicial authorities in holland
accused the
netherlands government of failing to
live up to its international obligations
on the
pollution amelioration front
and required
immediate action to be taken with
regards to nitrogen
pollution which admittedly can be a
problem now the plan that the
netherlands imposed by compulsion will
result in the destruction of a
substantial proportion
of the netherlands farming
uh infrastructure and the people who are
are promoting this say well we think the
sector can be resilient enough to
manage this but the farmers know
perfectly well that many of them are
going to be forced out of business as
the politicians themselves have not only
admitted but are aiming for and now
there is this approximately 30 reduction
in
the dutch
herd and the associated farms and the
politicians who are pushing this seem to
think that the whole agricultural sector
in the netherlands which is the world's
second biggest exporter of agricultural
products that the infrastructure there
will be able to tolerate this forced and
compelled reduction in supply and
consequent increases in costs but my
sense is the whole agricultural section
will
stagger and fall especially under the
weight of these
postcovid supply chain problems i mean i
can't see how you can take a whole
industry that runs on about a three to
five percent margin
force a 30
reduction in its inputs over an eight
year period and expect the whole system
to survive now they don't expect it to
survive they don't expect it to survive
oh okay we'll get into that now just to
add a little twist to that
now the dutch farmers are out protesting
there's 40 000 of them with their big
tractors and they don't do that lightly
because those tractors are expensive and
they're very busy and right in the
bloody midst of this our prime minister
did exactly the same thing he
unilaterally announced a mandatory 30
reduction in nitrogen output and he on
the farmers side and he wasn't even
willing to tie that to units of nitrogen
used per unit of food produced because
apparently he doesn't give a damn
whether we produce food effectively and
then that means that poor people will go
hungry
so what do you make of this again we
said
this isn't even good environmental
policy it's not going to work and i
don't know what's going to happen in sri
lanka but my suspicions are the people
are going to be cutting down the forests
and eating the animals because what the
hell else are they going to do
exactly
you're absolutely correct i don't
believe that they expect the survival of
the system and the the policies are
created largely because they don't
believe that system is worth keeping and
they've said it to the to the uh farmers
in the netherlands they've said that to
them in some places the nitrogen
reduction content is up to 90 of its
near conservation right in the
netherlands up to 90
and when and and remember these farmers
including our farmers they have been
approached about this net zero before
this is not the first time
and they were told if you invest in
innovative technologies
that would bring down um your carbon
footprint and therefore you would get
some you would get some credits for that
and so many of those farmers in the
netherlands they spent millions of
dollars
investing in innovative technology and
then after that the government said what
that's not good enough then they brought
in the nitrogen requirements so then
they imposed the nitrogen requirements
upon an already fragile industry and
then the dutch farmer said well we will
not be able exactly like in sri lanka to
make the yields that it would it would
be worth financially us continuing this
industry and what did the government say
well if your farms can't sustain
itself they're not sustainable we'll buy
them or a corporation will buy them from
you but it's not we cannot continue to
invest in an unsustainable business and
when the dutch farmers come out and say
well we are one of the largest exporters
of cash crops
certain cash crops what does the
government say oh no you're not you
import a lot of the things that you need
to produce that and so when you minus
that from the equation you're actually
negligible in the world scheme of the
food supply chain so they have an answer
for everything and and not only that
when the dutch farmer said okay
let's look at if this is really about
the environment and the canadian farmers
are saying the same thing let's look at
our contribution
and
the contribution that we make to carbon
um sequestration when we plant crops
carbon is sequestered uh in in the in
the soil and so do we get in canada the
questions asked do we get a reduction
from our carbon tax that we're paying to
to dry the crops can we reduce can we
get a reduction on that carbon tax and
the question the answer is no in in the
netherlands what was the the answer the
the government basically said well no
you don't get to do the calculations
we we're the ones who set the
calculations so the metrics that they
don't even want to negotiate on the
metrics which tells you how dictatorial
this whole process is when you cannot
even have people who have tended to the
land for generations who are probably
some of the most experienced farmers in
the world where you say their input is
not valid it tells you that there is a
an agenda beyond just protecting the
environment because if it were just
protecting the environment you would
want all of these viable inputs and you
would want to say okay this practice if
it can be done in a sustainable manner
let's do it no you impose a restriction
that you know will kill the industry
okay so so i'm going to walk through a
bunch of that okay so
so let's let's lay out the argument here
on the progressive side and take it
apart
okay so the first argument is
oh no the environmental apocalypse is
coming
okay so now let's think about that is an
apocalypse coming well we've heard about
various apocalypses for the last 40
years and
many of them needed to be taken
seriously and so we could say there's
some threat but let's let's walk through
that a little bit more it's like okay we
can see bad things coming in the future
now my question would be well who's
qualified to deal with those
hypothetical emergencies now here's a
psychological answer you tell me what
you think about this because i've just
been formulating it
so
one of the things you do as a therapist
when people are afraid of something is
you teach them how to
confront it voluntarily
and maybe someone's afraid of
other people they're socially anxious so
they don't like going to parties
and so you might say well your
assignment for this week is to go to a
party and the person says
well that makes me too afraid i don't
think i can do it and i'll get irritable
and it isn't going to work and so you
say okay well
let's scale it back to find something
you can do that doesn't paralyze you and
make you irritable
and so maybe you say well you go say
hello to the person who runs your corner
store and introduce yourself that's your
assignment for the week and then they go
out and see if they can do that and so
so you don't want to
confront people with a monster that's so
big that it terror terrifies them into
paralysis
or
turns them into a tyrant
let's say
so now you're an environmentalist and
you're facing the apocalypse and you say
oh my god i'm so terrified of this that
i'm virtually paralyzed
and then you say not only that it's such
an emergency
that i'm 100 justified in using
compulsion
on others
not bringing them along voluntarily not
developing a shared vision not talking
in detail to the dutch or the canadian
farmers who are among the most efficient
utilizers of resources per unit of food
grown in the world none of that it's top
down and so then i would say look
if your vision of the future is so
apocalyptic that you're
paralyzed into paralysis or you're
terrified into paralysis and you've
become a tyrant
then you're not the right person for the
job
your own psychological reaction is
showing that instead you should be out
there
talking to people the farmers in
particular let's say and maybe we could
throw in the truckers for good measure
who actually have to deal with these
things on a day-to-day basis
to find a shared vision it's not like
the bloody farmers want to spend any
more money on fertilizer than they have
to
and get people to come along voluntarily
and so here's the moral hazard
all right
it's the apocalypse that's the claim we
need
net zero
because that means we don't have to
think about all the painful details
this
is terrifying us because it's such an
emergency and therefore conveniently for
us we need all the decision-making power
and we need it now
and so the problem here is that the
apocalypse justifies the emergence of a
tyrant
and that's what we're seeing play out
now i'll add one more detail to that
you said
and what we both we both discussed the
idea that even by
the measures that the environmentalists
use these policies appear to be
counterproductive they're going to
destroy the industries they're going to
throw people into poverty they're going
to produce social chaos and so then you
think well okay if they know if they
don't know this then that's unforgivable
ignorance if they do know it then it's
unforgivable malevolence and you might
say well what's driving that how about
if we had to choose between destroying
capitalism and saving the environment we
would choose destroying capitalism
well
you you've packed a lot into that and
what i do want to do is is just to turn
back to like this whole climate change
narrative
so
we know climate change is both man-made
and it is natural the problem is is that
our solutions
of course they're they're only focused
on the man-made component and they want
you to believe that it's only man-made
which which it's that's not true um but
that's all we could do is is affect that
man-made component
the hypocrisy that we see in the
policies is what i have a problem with
every day we're importing 555
um barrels of oil a day
into canada
555 000
and yet we're importing them from
often dictatorship regimes with poorer
environmental records than ours so we're
rewarding bad behavior
and yet we're saying that we cannot
develop our natural resources but we're
admittingly stating that we have not
moved past the point where we can live
without those natural resources so
that's one sense of the hypocrisy that i
see another sense is yes you're right we
it is a deliberate attempt to kill
certain industries for example
they have been programming us for years
that eating beef is selfish
and and that if you continue to eat meat
you're a selfish person they've it's
they've been programming us to want to
eat bugs and to not want to eat
especially beef
and so you see this predictive
programming coming out and when you
juxtapose that with something that they
say is one of their saviors like
electric cars and you say okay we're
gonna do a net zero analysis of beef and
and they like to do that and they will
say that state that you ate dr peterson
last night well you have to take into
consideration the entire life cycle of
that cattle that you ate and so they
start from the farm they look at all of
the feces and the dung excreted from
that cattle over its lifetime its impact
on runoff into the water if they look at
how much grass that cattle has eaten
and then they look at the transportation
cost to get that piece of
nice beef on your plate that you ate
last night
and they say well when you do the net
zero calculation that piece of beef is
not sustainable
but
let's take an electric car
they do not start
from in a cobalt mine
in africa
or even for a computer in a lithium mine
in africa with a poor five-year-old
child that if you looked at the
just the abuse that that child had to
endure your heart would melt it is it's
just such egregious circumstances
outrageous circumstances that that those
children are put under and yet these are
the minors of the uh components that we
need in order to go in that electric car
so they don't start there
then you look at the battery
right and no let's look at the fact that
the battery has to be charged
what is it charged with
it's charged with carbon
but yet that's not included in the
carbon footprint
and then you look at the battery the
disposal of that battery at the end of
the life cycle of that car
and you know that the d to decompose
that battery will take i think by one
calculation i don't quote me i think i
heard 75 years
so
when you look at the life cycle of that
and you do a net net zero calculation on
that you will see
that it is not as green as we are
told that it is and many of the green
products are not as green
well didn't the eu a month ago
redefine green to include natural gas
and nuclear which begs a major question
which is well
why weren't they defined that way to
begin with and
what's the grounds for the
reclassification and well on the nuclear
front that's been bothering me for years
it's like while france has done a pretty
good job
providing a stable power grid for a
number of decades now and that's about
as green as it gets uh
there's the problem of disposal of
nuclear waste but that's a manageable
problem there's always a problem with
energy solutions i just can't help but
see that
and i've watched the environmentalist
leftists
do this internal
battle of ethics because the left at
least in principle
let's say they have two broad concerns
well three one is amelioration of
absolute poverty
another is amelioration of relative
poverty that's the inequality argument
and the other the third is something
like environmental sustainability
and so then you might say well what
happens when those
goals run into
paradoxical juxtaposition
and so then you have to decide if you're
going to save the planet or you're going
to save the poor
and the answer on the environmental
front as far as i can tell continually
has been oh to hell with the poor we're
going to save the planet and then the
catastrophe of that is well if you don't
save the poor along with the planet then
you doom the planet and the poor
and that seems like a really bad
solution to me we'll get back to more
with dr leslie lewis in just a second
first we want to tell you about shopify
designed for anyone to sell anywhere
shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
an all-in-one e-commerce platform
shopify helps business owners achieve
independence by making it easier to
start run and grow your online
storefront shopify reduces the barriers
to business ownership by making good
e-commerce more accessible and intuitive
shopify helps you to find customers and
drive sales wherever you are online
market your business with built-in tools
for creation execution and analysis
manage orders shipping and payments and
gain the insights you need to scale your
business dedicated to empowering
independent business owners everywhere
millions of successful brands trust
shopify to sell ship and process
payments anywhere get started by
building and customizing your online
store no coding or design experience
required go to shopify.com
jbp for a free 14-day trial and get full
access to shopify's entire suite of
features start selling on shopify today
go to shopify.com jbp right now that's
shopify.com
jbp
it goes even deeper to look at the fact
that the net zero calculation now is uh
basically an attempt to really
transition us from one um economic mode
of production to a new one and it's been
very very clearly stated um it's been
very clearly stated by klaus schwab in
his book the great reset um which is not
a conspiracy you can find it on amazon
um and that's not a pitch for him
it's also a terrible book it's a
terrible book you know it's i i read
that book it is full of platitudes it's
full of platitudes that book yeah
and there's there's not a lot of um
substantiating the grand theories in the
book but it is a grand theory of of
where
they see
our entire society going and one of the
big champions of of this grand theory is
justin trudeau he wants to remake our
society in a post-nationalist image of
what he considers to be a
egalitarian
flat society um but there are still a
lot of inequities if you look at the the
recent conference that they had in in
davos they basically put
limousines on
jets in order to get them over there so
that they could be driven around in
luxury but yet they they want to limit
the travel of average canadians and so
you see this dichotomy and this
two-tiered society being created one
where they're going after the food
supply chain to control your consumption
and the only way they can do that is
through the farmers then the second
thing is to go after your consumption
and daily purchasing which will come
through um environmental social
governance and the environmental social
governance program is a completely uh
new international
accounting program that requires small
and medium-sized businesses to allocate
the carbon footprint of every single
product that they sell and and and to
quantify that different users will have
different products your cap you may use
your camera uh once a year on vacation
and another person may use it every day
to film so the the carbon footprint it's
it's almost impossible to measure but
yet they're coming up with this system
which can only be implemented by lawyers
accountants consultants so you have the
lawyers the accountants and and and and
contractors getting wealthy while small
businesses will be struggling to under
more red tape than they have now to to
be able to meet these standards of this
environmental social governance and the
ironic thing about this dr peterson is
that in if these same companies are
operating say in china or or overseas
they these same canadian companies do
not have to subject
those citizens
and that country um
purchasers to that same level of
tracking the carbon footprint right well
so this is a crucial this is a crucial
issue here because one of the things we
really have to understand is that
if we don't
develop our ability to
generate and disseminate cheap energy in
the developed countries where we have
high
not only high standards of environmental
stewardship on the legal front but an
ethos of environmental stewardship among
the distributed business class it's
already there they're already aiming at
that all that's going to happen is that
worse providers elsewhere are going to
be
uh brought aboard as you said we're
buying oil from well let's say canada
isn't i don't think we import oil from
russia but obviously the europeans
import fossil fuels from russia like mad
all we're doing is enabling
the chinese and the dictatorial gulf
states to
fill in the gaps let's say absolutely i
cannot see in any possible way how
that's going to be good for poor people
or good for the environment in any sense
whatsoever and i think your comments
about trudeau being a poster boy for the
klaus schwab and the wef types and also
your comments on esgs which everyone
should know about
the esg mandates that are coming in at
the corporate level if we get snookered
into a digital currency which seems to
me to be highly probable then not only
are corporate expenses going to have to
be accounted for in terms of their
hypothetical carbon footprint but every
bloody purchase that individuals make is
going to be subject to exactly the same
kind of analysis and taxation and
nudging and pressure and so every
consumer decision we make is going to be
weighed up in terms of our
environmental impact
for no good outcome let's let's make
that clear to make everything more
expensive to make energy more expensive
to make food more inaccessible to hurt
the planet to make it more difficult for
people to conduct their business and for
poor people to starve that's the bloody
vision that's being put forth by the
half-wit cliche mongers like like klaus
schwab well let me first speak about the
first point that you made about um bad
actors so we have the
um the third largest accessible oil
reserves on the planet in canada which
we leave largely untapped and right now
in europe 40
of their uh supply is coming from russia
if we were able to develop our natural
resources even get our lng to tidewater
get it over to europe we could actually
offset uh
dependency on russian oil and so you're
absolutely right that the the need is
still there and the fact that our
government has implemented uh industry
killing policies like bill c-48 and bill
c-69
that is basically just to stymie our
production it is the same thing that
when we implement these policies on our
farmers it's really affecting our global
supply chain when we have these social
governance uh rules that are imposed on
um canadians businesses it means that we
will not be producing at the level that
we we should be producing we are
actually being
dependent on um foreign countries to
produce and import it and that's why we
we we will continue to have such large
trade deficits um and trade deficits
some people will say well that tells you
that you have a rich nation and you
don't have to produce everything but we
see what dependency can cause during
covid are basic ppes we had to import
where we had the capacity to to produce
those here and so we have to make sure
that we're optimizing our capacity i
also want to touch on the digital um id
and and this whole digitization
of our economy yes it is a transition to
a new economy the
the plan is for everything our even the
way our uh gdp would be calculated would
be based on a new means of calculation
that would have ingrained in it the
carbon footprint and so the carbon
footprint is is almost going to replace
what we know as our dollar and when we
see centralized digital banking
currencies
when we see that emerging that is
creating the infrastructure and arguably
you could even argue that things such as
digital currencies were a test ground
for creation of that infrastructure of
the new economy that's why i think that
my inclusion in in the leadership race
and in the future of canada is so
important because i've spent years
studying what it is that has that we've
been embarked upon many people do not
understand
what what is happening how every
calculation everything that you do will
be logged on that blockchain the
blockchain could see every single
transaction um
and and it's going to be recorded and
our entire lives are going to be equated
on
how much carbon footprint we contribute
to society or how good we are at
reducing our carbon footprint right
right right so so that'll be the
hallmark by which all ethical conduct
will be evaluated and we're setting up
an infrastructure where there can be
complete tracking of everything in
relationship to that and you might say
well the planet's in terrible shape and
the first thing we need to do is to
reduce our carbon footprint but then i
think well wait a second this this goes
back to your discussion about the depth
of analysis let's say on the electric
car front it's like well wait a second
are you so sure like 100 to the bottom
of your soul that the most important
thing we could possibly embark upon
is carbon output reduction and nothing
else so let me offer some other
alternatives if we're going to look at
this in a broader sense and i got a fair
bit of this from people like marion
toopey and bjorn lomberg it's like well
lomborg has put together teams of
economists to analyze where we get the
biggest return per dollar spent which
isn't a bad metric unless you have a
better one um and he he rank ordered the
un's sustainability goals in terms of
economic viability and so let's make
that clear
they're important things to pursue
internationally and nationally one of
the ways we determine
what's most important and should be
funded is by looking at something like
return on investment if we spend a
dollar how much money does that generate
in return and lomberg who put together
10 teams of economists who worked
independently on this and then at and
then aggregated across their findings
that showed that climate remediation
spending doesn't even enter the top 20
that if we really wanted to put the
planet together in some long-term sense
over the next few decades we'd be
funneling a lot more money into such
things as absolute poverty reduction for
for poor children in the developing
world because the return on investment
for early childhood nutrition for
example is about two hundred and fifty
dollars to one
and so
it
on the environmental side well and i can
think of other environmental issues that
are more pressing so for example
i worked on the u.n committee that set
up some of the sustainability goals and
so i looked at this for a long time
and i do think there are environmental
problems and
climate change is one of them but where
it should be placed on the list is not
exactly clear um certainly i would say
the problem of oceanic mismanagement is
much more not only pressing and and
vital but also remediable for we
actually know how to remediate it and
trying to generate any public discussion
on that front is virtually impossible
and so the environmentalists themselves
they jump on one issue
it's climate change
they say oh it's going to be a
catastrophe and bjorn lomberg has done
these calculations he said look by the
year 2100
given current economic projections
we're going to be about four times
richer than we are now
but that's going to be decreased to some
degree because of the additional costs
of associated with climate change
but will only be
3.5 times richer
and then we can remediate most of that
he's also done a death calculation
showing that fewer people are likely to
die in the future when it's warmer than
die now because it's cold and more
people freeze to death than get
overheated and so in terms of human
catastrophe it's not obvious at all at
least at the present time that even if
you accept the ipcc climate change
prognostications which you might as well
for the sake of argument it is not clear
at all that bending and twisting our
entire infrastructure by compulsion and
force
immediately in an emergency reaction
that seeds all the power to the elite is
actually going to solve any of these
problems and not make them a lot worse
that is a very very good point and
therein lies the problem that that is
not their solution
their solution is really one to
transform
the our impact on the environment and
they believe that we are
over populated we have too many people
and so
we're over consuming and because of our
consumption patterns if we can bring
down our consumption patterns then we
will be able to
reduce um the impact on the environment
so that's essentially what they are
trying to do well that argument hey i i
put out a youtube video last week i
wrote an article for the telegraph about
a deloitte memo
uh report that was produced in may and
the deloitte consultants
who are the davos types basically said
well you know we're facing this
environmental catastrophe and so we got
to put the brakes on economic growth and
sure that's going to cause some
disruption in the short term meaning you
know the next five decades
but it'll be worth it at some point in
the future and i think well hold on a
second here
you put a lot of economic pressure on
the world uh supply chain system food
production energy you're gonna starve a
lot of really poor people and somehow
you think that's okay it's like here's
the deal the apocalypse is so nigh that
we're gonna have to throw a billion or
two billion people into absolute poverty
again to make things better it's like
what's your evidence that's going to
make things better
is sri lanka your evidence
their aim is is more behavior
modification and behavior modification
of largely industrialized western
nations and so they can track that if
everything is digitized if we all have
um digital ids if our digital ids then
are used to
facilitate and navigate us through
society so whether it is
financial whether it's a it's a purchase
whether it's healthcare so your digital
id will be tied into the system and then
you can monitor your your consumption um
based on that even in the united states
right now like you could go into i think
it's walgreens and they have free um uh
coolers with products inside with locks
on it in the future it's predicted that
those locks you will be able to put in
your digital id if you've had too much
sugar that ice cream fridge won't open
for you and so it's it's a way to
monitor your behavior and that's what
people are not looking at they're not
looking at all of the promises that have
come out of the world economic forum and
they're not taking it very very
seriously because
we've had klaus schwab
clearly state that he has penetrated
canada's cabinet and to me that's a very
very serious thing for a global
businessman to say
about
an independent democracy i and and and
we have even our finance minister that's
sitting on the board uh one of the
boards of the world economic forum
many canadians are very very concerned
about that and i think as a strong
opposition we need to ask questions
about that because if these are concerns
for canadians why are why are we afraid
to delve into these issues of someone
who has shown such an utter disrespect
for our democracy to say that he's
penetrated our cabinet well you know i
talked to some people who went to these
devos conferences a while back
and who stopped going because of the
twist that it took and i said well
i asked them very credible people by the
way
i asked them well who is klaus schwab
anyways
and the answer was
well he's a conference organizer
i said well how did he develop such a
position of undue influence and they
said well he was very good at bringing
um
what would you say influential people
together and helping them network and
that elevated them into a position of
well unparalleled authority in some
sense it's like yeah fine but
we're going to sacrifice our national
sovereignty to
this international cabell of misinformed
what would you call it you two
misinformed low-risk
utilities who are willing to sacrifice
the world's poor that's the plan that
seems like a really bad plan okay so let
me let me push back at you on something
here so now people who are listening to
this especially critics of the way that
you're thinking are going to say well
there's dr lewis getting all
conspiratorial and uh you know isn't
that just typical of a social
conservative type so you talked about
the danger of esgs and everyone
listening should know what those are esg
that's worse than diversity inclusivity
and equity by the way by a large margin
and so there's the esg problem there's
the digital id problem there's the
globalist utopian centralizing problem
why shouldn't you just be dismissed as a
socially conservative conspiracy
theorists what makes you think
and this is really a serious question
you know because the world's pretty
weird right now and it's not that easy
to protect yourself against becoming
conspiratorial let's say
or seeing conspiracies what makes you
think that your analysis of this
situation is
is balanced and reasonable and that
canadians could rely on you for your
judicious wisdom
well
you've earned a phd so you know the grit
and the rigor that it goes through that
you go through to earn a phd so i
respect knowledge uh any information
that i put out there i it's well
researched i often if i'm quoting
somebody it's from their own words the
problem is is that the the term
conspiracy theory has been used to in
order to absolve politicians of their
responsibility to answer questions it is
it it's a psychopterm that that's been
used to gaslight um even right now the
united nations has a program that they
put out on conspiracy theories on how to
deal with a conspiracy theory what they
tell you is that if you see something
that you don't agree with that you
believe is a conspiracy theory report
the person write to their editor this is
all a form of bullying um
labeling something as a conspiracy
theory is an easy way for you not to
deal with the issue at hand by just
dismissing it me someone with a phd
i respect knowledge and i have taken
a lot of time to write to the members of
the conservative party and everything i
write i documented at one point when i
was telling people that our government
in enrolled in a program called the
known traveler digital id program which
is a world economic forum program people
said no that cannot be why would our
government enroll in the known traveler
digital id program with the world
economic forum when i sent them the link
and they can go directly to canada to
the government of canada's website they
could see that we actually have done
these things so many things what the
government does is that they they put
people in a place of willful blindness
to make them feel that embarrassed
somehow for actually listening to the
things that they tell them that they're
going to do justin trudeau
after covid said this is an opportunity
for us to reset and re-imagine our
future he said that he used those words
then when people said
when people said oh this is what you're
planning to do then he says oh no it's a
conspiracy they're gaslighting you and
to be honest with you i'm a very
educated person and and i do not care if
somebody labels me a conspiracy theorist
because it just means that they're not
intelligent enough to argue with me
that's all it means and so i do i really
don't care
my goal is i'm going to save my country
i'm going to do everything that i can to
save my country i'm going to invest
every single ounce of my skill set to
making sure that i remain a canadian
citizen and not a global citizen and i
am going to in continue to inform people
so there's no shame you can call me
anything you want i'm going to continue
to speak i'm going to continue to get my
message out there and i'm going to
continue to send canadians information
and substantiate what i say with
information
so canadians can be informed about what
their government is planning for them
all right so you're in this race with
pauliev
charest
charade bobber and hsn and pauliev is
the front runner
at the moment um by quite a substantial
margin you have no but you but you keep
saying that but you haven't provided me
with any documentation to to
substantiate that in fact the media will
want you to believe that okay well let
me well let me ask let me ask you this
let me ask you this then
so my understanding is that pauliev
was ahead of the rest of the candidates
on the conservative front in terms of
number of memberships sold in the
conservative party is that correct
that's what he said that's not i i have
seen no proof of that that's what he
said he revealed those numbers i can
tell you that many of the people that
signed up on his website were my
supporters because he sent messages to
everybody's supporters telling them to
sign up on their website so even a few
days before the membership ended people
who had already signed up with me got a
message from his campaign saying that
they were members so they went and
resigned so there were a lot of
duplicates in there so we do not have
the accurate numbers on who sold what
where do you see the relative
how do you conceptualize the relative
standing of the current candidates
within the conservative membership so
just so that everyone's listening is
clear
so what happens when a new
party member party leader is chosen is
that only party members can vote and so
the first vote in canada will be for the
leader of the conservative party and
there's a number of candidates who are
running and that vote is in september in
mid-september and so how do you see the
relative standing of the current crop of
candidates within the conservative party
so i sold i sold substantially more uh
memberships this time
than the last time when i won the
popular vote um i do not want to get
into the numbers because when you add up
what mr paulie have said what mr brown
said the existing numbers it's
impossible so i know that there are
untruths there and i don't think that
there's any benefit for me in weighing
in that way what i can tell you is that
of we now have the membership list and
we've reached out to the membership list
i can tell you mr polyeff is very strong
but mr charae is not ahead of me the
media will want you to believe that mr
charade is ahead of me because they have
been promoting him in fact i've done
phenomenally well with almost no media
attention and the media will try to push
as much as they can the candidate that
they prefer of course they don't prefer
me because i i speak a lot of truths
that they just do not want to engage in
at this at this time but canadians are
listening canadians are doing their
research there's lots of information out
there and the membership is very very
interested in a number of issues that
people are not talking about
such as the impact of global
organizations upon our sovereignty
right right which seems to be a
particular a particular and pointed
concern of yours and so
okay so
let me ask you then
what distinguishes you apart from your
concern
about the influence undue influence of
these international organizations
what distinguishes you from the other
candidates why should canadians vote for
you compared to them and then also i
would like to hear
we've
we've spent a lot of time delving into a
criticism let's say of the utopian
globalist environmental top-down
approach to
planetary stewardship i'd like to hear
something about
if you could have the canada you wanted
it's canada that you would work towards
as leader of the conservative party and
and putative prime minister what would
canada look like under your stewardship
let's start with the
comparative question first on the
conservative front what are you offering
what are you bringing to canadians that
distinguishes you from the other
candidates
well i am not a career politician i
have just entered politics and so i can
relate with average canadians i know
what it's like to
not know where money is going to come
from to pay your bills at the end of the
month i know what it's like to start a
business from ground up and not be able
to draw a salary because you have to pay
your employees i know what it's like to
stand in a grocery line and not know
whether or not your debit card is going
to go through i can connect with average
average canadians whereas career
politicians they've had paychecks that
have been given to them
by the tax from the taxpayers i have
signed the front of a paycheck the
average politician has only signed the
back of a paycheck and so that ability
to relate to average canadians is
something that i think is very important
i also think my educational and
experiential background is something
that's really topical and needed at this
particular time in our nation's history
at this particular time as i said we
have a lot of international
organizations encroaching on our
freedoms and on and on our liberties and
somebody with international experience
that can dissect these treaties and
understand how these treaties affect our
sovereignty is very very important i
also believe as as an educator i've
taught as i said at york university
university toronto osgood hall law
school and
i am an educator and so i can break down
complex issues i don't speak to
canadians through slogans and talking
points i speak to their hearts because i
can connect with them on these issues
and some high level issues that most
many politicians would say
it's not worth discussing that with them
i'm able to communicate
with canadians and give them in
informative information that will allow
them to make an educated decision and i
think that that is some of the main
differencing factors um for me okay so
you i'm going to sum that up so you said
well you you come from a background
that's similar say economically to the
bulk of canadians you also have that in
that struggling immigrant experience
very close to you and your family
you you've started your own business i
want to ask you a few questions about
that so you're familiar with uh with
what would you say enterprise
enterprises on the entrepreneurial front
which is a big deal you're very highly
educated person and one of the things
that
is very interesting about your resume is
that your education is very diverse
especially given your political stance
because you're quite well versed in
postmodern and marxist thought given
your education in sociology women's
studies and and environmental studies
and then we can add to that which i want
to talk about as well yours your legal
studies and then your teaching
so and then you're also an educator and
so so that's a nice that's a nice
combination as you said especially now
navigating the complex things we're
navigating we got to your master's
degree at york tell me a little bit
about two things about your legal
training and your teaching and then
about your business
so by way of background legal training i
started off on bay street in a firm
called goodman and car they've since
merged into different firms and i had
quite good
bay street experience then i went to
learners which is also a large
litigation firm and then ended at
thomson rogers thereafter i made the
decision to
i thought have a more balanced life
with young children and a new family and
so
we made the decision that i would start
my own business and that gave me
an opportunity to to work late at night
while being at home wake up early in the
morning and and have more quality time
with my family so you were at some big
firms and and tell me also about the
details of your of your legal education
you have a phd in law from from osgoode
hall from osgoode from moscow that's one
of
toronto or canada's top law schools by
the way and so you have that that
stellar legal education which is not an
easy thing to obtain and then you have
large law firm experience which by the
way is also not easy to attain because
the
application process for
um articling at these firms is extremely
intense and the process of moving
towards um partnership is extremely
competitive like and i mean
exceptionally competitive and so then
you have
small children you have children and you
had a family you decided to start your
own firm
yes
okay and tell me about that tell me what
that was like and when you did that
oh that that was really interesting
because so i came from bay street which
you have large clients
and uh fortunately my last job on bay
street i was working for a
it was the largest personal injury law
firm at that time and so you had a
combination of um corporate clients
insurance companies and you also had
personal injury clients so i was able to
transition that way because my clients
liked me and so i was able to buy out
my clientele and transition it to my new
firm but the problem is is that personal
injury the lawyers have to carry the the
file so they pay for all the medicals
etc uh because the the
injured party is usually not working and
so i that put a lot of financial strain
um it was uh we had i had numerous
discussions with my husband about the
strain that it was putting on our family
being able to do that because i had to
get a line of credit to do that and so i
had to go for low-hanging fruit because
those claims settled in two years so i
had to go for low-hanging fruit so i
decided to pick up criminal law because
that way you could do quick bail
hearings and then i was doing some duty
council per diem work which would um
which basically you were basically like
a a court lawyer a crown lawyer um but
for the defense side doing duty council
and you would get paid from the
government so i picked that up doing
that per diem
filling in and also then trying to do
some private criminal cases in order to
sustain things as as i went along and
then after that i i had to pick up real
estate too
to kind of make ends meet and then i
added on a really unique area of
immigration so you were like a sole
practitioner initially in just taking
whichever files because you had to pay
the bills
and so i added on immigration and then i
developed into a very niche area of
immigration dealing with um lgbtq cases
um from refugee cases of people who were
fleeing their country because of lgbtq
plus persecution
are you sure you're not a closet leftist
operative i mean you've got women's
studies you've got sociology and
environment and now you were a lawyer on
the lgbtq
plus front
on immigration issues i think you're i
think you're probably a close schwab
plant
no on refugee issues because these
people well well think about it it no
matter how
um what your political beliefs are if
you see somebody being persecuted and
running for their life and is going to
be killed because of their sexual
orientation it's just
humanity would tell you that if you have
skills
uh you would lend it to those
individuals to me it's it's a no-brainer
right i had the skill set that i could
work in these communities and and so i
did and so um to me that's just a human
thing to do and i i just live my life
like that um i try to live my life to
honor my upbringing which is an
upbringing based on faith which is
loving your neighbor as yourself and
that means standing in a role that is
very
non-judgmental of people and doing the
right thing and as a lawyer i pledged to
help those who are in need to me it's no
different than if you're a criminal
lawyer and you're put on a a case where
somebody um
it's it's a murder case you may have to
work on that case
so okay so so
so we we walk through what distinguishes
you from the other candidates um and
what you bring to the table
your your your business acumen your
legal extensive legal training and
practice in multiple areas
including large law firms and then all
these private practice niches that you
carved out which i suspect would make
quite a story in and of itself as you're
doing that with small kids in a
developing family and outside the
protective net of the big law firms
competitive as they are
very
diverse
in the positive sense of the word
educational background
including an emphasis on the kind of law
that would make you an astute analyst of
international agreements as well as an
educator final question i think before
we switch to the daily wire section
which is a behind-the-scenes look at the
development of your career
if you could have the canada you wanted
as leader of the country 10 years down
the road
what what would you focus and
concentrate on what would you bring to
the table for canadians
the most important thing that i see is
really our freedoms and our sovereignty
i would want a canada
in which i am still a canadian citizen
and i'm very concerned that we are
moving towards a global citizenship
and so the preservation of our
sovereignty would be one of the main
things that i focus on and in preserving
our sovereignty i we need to preserve
our um our
institutions that that really make this
country great and right now what we're
seeing is a
nihilistic approach to eliminating all
of the institutions upon which this
country was founded on we're seeing an
erosion of our military our army and
erosion you're seeing movements to
defund the police you're seeing an
erosion of our family uh parental rights
parents are feeling that they don't have
the right to raise their children in
accordance with with their own values
parents are feeling that that
governments are encroaching too much on
their parental sovereignty and these are
loving parents who would ordinarily do
the right thing
but governments are stacked stepping in
locus parentis and and acting as if they
are the guardians and the soul
custodians over children and they have
stated that and we have seen even some
united nations programs if you look at
the comprehensive sex education program
um that the united nations is pushing
with uh planned parenthood you can see
that there's an undermining of of of the
the fabric of of our of our society uh
in in terms of um
in terms of parental rights and in terms
of what parents believe that their
children should be exposed to at a age
appropriate
level
okay so you're looking at
a a platform that insists upon
individual autonomy and responsibility
the same thing being true at the family
level the same thing being true at the
civic level
and then preservation canadian
sovereignty and and yes yes
the economic level is imperative also
because that is what i believe is is
going to be the impetus in in
transitioning us from a from canadian
citizenship to global citizenship so
we have to ensure that we can
continue to remain economically viable
bringing our supply chains home making
sure that we produce
what we need in order to sustain
ourselves optimizing our potential
encouraging industries like in our
agricultural industry encouraging our
resource development uh
being good stewards of of the resources
that we have been granted right now even
off the coast of the arctic we have uh
countries like china and russia actually
mining freely mining our minerals we
have no protection of that why because
we have not invested in our military
russia has 40 submarine
icebreakers we have zero we don't have
we we don't even have the capacity to
protect our own resources in our own
arctic and so
a
functioning and vibrant canada
recognizes not just investment in our
human potential in the the fabric of our
society but also recognizing that we can
be self-sustaining both economically and
politically and when i say politically
i mean from a standpoint of of keeping
global organizations at bay and
recognizing our sovereignty and not
taking our cues from organizations like
the wef the world economic forum the
w.h.o the the world health organization
and uh the united nations we need to
ensure that any treaties that we sign on
to does not
undermine our national sovereignty
all right well
that sounds like a fairly comprehensive
package it reminds me there's a
principle of subsidiarity i think that
was originally insisted upon by the
catholics but that's become part of
conservative political doctrine which is
that
every responsibility should be meted out
to the most proximal possible source
so for example for each individual has a
domain of responsibility that shouldn't
be encroached on by the family and each
family has a domain of responsibility
that shouldn't be encroached on by the
community and the towns have their level
that the provinces and states should
leave alone and the states have their
level that the federal government should
leave alone and so forth and so an
intelligent conservatism distributes
responsibility all the way down the
hierarchy to the level of the individual
and that protects us against the kind of
tower of babel
global overreach that the
utopian globalists seem to be insisting
upon compelling us to support and so you
see yourself as far as i can tell i
don't believe i'm putting words into
your mouth as a as a
locus of resistance and alternative
vision to that top-down utopian
um
scheming let's say does that seem
reasonable oh absolutely that that's a
very succinctly summarizes exactly how i
feel and
looking at the last two years we have
seen the manifestation of that
frustration that comes out of that
utopian ideal and we witnessed that in
in the trucker protest and we also that
that is such a good example of how our
systems our institutions are breaking
down when we look at the coverage that
the truckers got it was it was really uh
a lot of lies that the media spread
about russian collusion and intervention
and and made it seem like a violent
protest even though i walked to to
parliament every single day and so did
the other mps and we actually saw things
that were very very communal focused uh
kids on jumping castles people cooking
for each other we uh witness uh groups
of people coming together whether
they're sikhs or uh christians and
praying and praying for the country and
so the the coverage that we saw from our
media was extremely atrocious and it it
shows you that we do not have a
functioning legacy media right now they
are acting as an arm of the liberal
government and that is not healthy for a
democracy and so we have to start uh
looking at how we can
realign many of these institutions that
have under this utopian ideal have now
started to disintegrate it's it's very
important and when we look at um even
what we're seeing here we are having um
vestiges of of the coercive state
apparatuses left over right now we still
have the arrive can app fully mobile
where canadians cannot come into their
own country even though their passport
allows them to have free entry in and
out our charter of rights under section
two of the charter guarantees our
freedom of mobility yet we have an app
that we know that the government has
disclosed that that app should only be
used in mandatory situations where there
is a
a global pandemic or where there is an
emergency order we know that no such
orders in place yet we still have the
remnants of of that totalitarian
coercive state apparatus pushed on us
and those are the things that we have to
continue to push back on for um us to
continue to have our freedom upheld we
have to continue to say
these things um
are contrary to our charter yeah and to
the spirit of the spirit that's made
canada one of the leading democracies in
shining lights in the world absolutely
you know we have a crisis of trust i
would say in the west and maybe in the
world at large and that's a very bad
thing because trust is the fundamental
currency
why are you convinced personally
that you could be entrusted with a task
such as this and why should canadians
take
the confidence that you and your family
let's say have in you why should they
take that seriously like why should you
be believed and trusted
and you know
and what concerns do you have about that
oh it's a great question because to be
honest with you i'm i'm involved in
politics i don't like politics and and i
put out a a
letter to that effect to the
members the other day and and many
people were shocked for me to say that i
don't like it i don't like it because i
find it very contrived i find that
that politicians will say things because
they know either the polls agree with
them or they'll get a vote
personally i don't care about that at
the beginning when i was a very early i
was just a few months into being a
member of parliament i had to make the
tough decision i believed in medical
privacy and i
saw that what our government was doing
was infringing on people's personal
private medical histories and i knew
that at that time at that time i knew
that the vaccine didn't prevent um you
getting coveted or spreading covet and
so i was trying to understand
intellectually what all of this was
about why were we creating a segregation
society why did we have all these rules
when we knew
the truth of of um
of that it was just basically personal
responsibility and informed consent if
you wanted to take the the vaccine and
so i made the tough decision of not
divulging my vaccination status even
though i knew that i would not get a
shadow cabinet position i said cost it
what it may and i also made the tough
decision of
wrapping up my law firm i wanted that
firm to continue and i had lawyers that
were trained but um to to continue with
it but it was taking so much of my time
even to
to
just
keep it going and i knew that i had to
devote all of my energy into saving and
assisting my country down a path of of
of continuing our sovereignty and so
i've given up a lot and i believe and
i've also um i'm not doing this for for
money i was at the highest income
earning potential um and had great
opportunities i
another thing you probably say how did
she do so many things but i was
representing a number of canadian
corporations abroad on energy products
and so i it was a very lucrative time
for me and uh
leaving
a viable practice and also leaving the
prospect of being able to teach again in
university
are huge sacrifices and i believe that
for you to make those sacrifices um it
demonstrates a level of trust that you
can have in that person that they're
doing it for the right reason it's not
just a job it's not just a paycheck and
whether or not i
i win this leadership race i am very
content that
once you rub that genie in the bottle
and that genie comes out there are
issues that nobody else
are talking about that i have brought
out and that the canadian public now
knows that they have a voice in
parliament
that even if they come after my
reputation no matter what they do i'm
still going to be that voice of
canadians and so i think that when you
lay down your reputation in that way and
when you lend yourself to be a servant
of the people in that way that um that
earns trust and trust is something that
can't be demanded it's something that is
earned
that's a pretty uh ringing answer i
would say it's so delightful to be able
to sit down in these long forms and have
a real
discussion about such things that isn't
reduced to sound bites and that isn't a
mere reflection of yesterday's idiot
opinion poll
this has been a great conversation
i doing these 30-minute interviews with
all my guests now
discussing the
uh intricacies of their successful
careers and their journey forward
personally and the challenges that are
associated with that thank you very much
dr lewis i appreciate you taking the
time to do this i hope that everyone
listening has found this enlightening
and useful as i did it's nice to get to
know you and to see
well how much ground you've covered
before entering this political
territory which i think is a credit to
your
you know not putting the cart before the
horse it's nice to see someone emerge on
the political scene who has the wealth
of experience that you do in all these
domains that make you a credible
candidate on the national leadership
front
hello everyone i would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com